before we get started this video is
brought to you by Squarespace thank you
very much to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video I'll talk more about them a
little later in the video but for now
let's talk about how the nicest living
person portrayed the nicest person ever
[Music]
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
so a beautiful day in the neighborhood
is a mr. Rogers ish movie where Tom
Hanks plays the legend Fred Rogers it's
not really that it's not really about
mr. Rogers I mean he's in it but I
thought this is gonna be like a mr.
Rogers biopic see mr. Rogers his rise
may be some behind the scenes you do see
some behind the scenes but it takes
place in the late 90s it really revolves
around a journalist named Lloyd Vogel
when I was watching him I was like that
is John Ritter's son or Zach Braff's
brother turns out he's neither and funny
enough John Ritter and Zach Braff played
father and son in scrubs what is color
me shocked they're not related but Vogel
set to do a puff piece on mr. Rogers
he's like I'm gonna investigate a little
bit I'm gonna find out what's up is he
real is it real is mr. Rogers briefed
20% he actually leads a double life as
are lee ermey or one of his characters
we're gonna find out and released about
this reporter and his family dynamic he
and his father are estranged so you know
he needs to patch up his family dynamic
and enter mr. Rogers and the power of
positivity and undeniably I mean it's a
nice piece of positivity you don't walk
out all curmudgeon is like whatever
world you watch this movie you walk out
like yeah people are terrible something
about mr. Rogers won't you be my
neighbor a beautiful day in the
neighborhood where these movies come out
people like you know positivity a few
days later we're back to screaming at
each other online in all caps but hey
enjoy it while it's around Tom Hanks is
mr. Rogers when you first see him it
starts out I mean four by three aspect
ratio filmed like an episode of the show
like you're watching the show and at
first admittedly I was a little thrown
off I was like he doesn't look like mr.
Rogers wick enough though that subsides
and you're like oh no that's that's mr.
Rogers his sentence structure his
inflection the way he walks the way he
has those pauses not quite mid-sentence
but second to last word pause I think
we'd get Alka for a little family
healing but Matthew Reese the Lloyd
Vogel character the movie revolves
around him so it's his story he's the
one who really needs to carry it and for
the most part he does a good job he's a
good actor a couple bits of dialogue one
in particular where you're like oh he's
bringing it he's talking to his dad also
the movie and its structure really helps
you remember now this is a mr. Rogers
world the vehicle travel the transitions
it's done with little models like it's
mr. Rogers show there's that
one sequence in particular it's pretty
terrific that's actually the scene also
the fact that mr. Rogers calls this guy
at home the guy didn't even know he's
gonna call that mix with that trippy
scene mixed with a few other things I
was like I cannot wait for somebody to
edit this movie or at least a trailer
someone's totally gonna edit a trailer
for this movie and make it look like a
horror film it's an inevitability here
on YouTube just learn to love it I will
say if you take the mr. Rogers element
out if you can do the mental surgery
just be like what would this movie be if
he wasn't in it you would find yourself
watching a nice sweet Hallmark family
movie as Hallmark family movies are much
better acting in this movie than a
hallmark movie though need to address
that it kind of in a weird way does feel
like they had this script about this
estranged family that needs to come
together and they were like there are so
many of these things is there anything
we can interject into this movie to make
it stand out at all mr. Rogers perfect
it is based on a true story though I
don't know just say what it feels like
either way the movies nice it's nice
it's feel-good there's one scene in
particular words it's so feel-good you
start like what's happening it's just
kids singing on a subway what why are my
eyes leaking the power of Fred Rogers
I'll say a beautiful day in the
neighborhoods a feel good time no
alcohol required and as promised from
before sure as mentioned earlier in the
video this video is brought to you by
Squarespace Squarespace makes it easy to
build a website with a lot of great
looking templates you do not need
exhaustive experience in the fine art of
website building I know I've said that
before but as the great Arwen once said
to that tae-ho I'm gonna try to do a
movie reference every time there's a
sponsorship I'm gonna try I do that in
life anyway so it's no different when is
Squarespace is easy accessible and
professional-looking and I always
appreciate that and Squarespace lets you
auto post content from your website to
Twitter Facebook Tumblr and yes the list
goes on you can purchase domains
directly from Squarespace so try it out
for free when you're ready click the
link below to squarespace.com slash
John's enter promo code John's upon
checkout and save yourself ten percent
off your first domain purchase so try it
out check it out and thank you once
again the Squarespace for sponsoring
this video I appreciate it I saw a
beautiful day in the neighborhood have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite feel cook movie
the movie that really just tugs at the
string whatever it is whatever II think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]